five everybody welcome to Monday yeah
we're very excited today we have
communion after Theo von with us Theo
von is Netflix special no offense drops
February 26 February 26 on Netflix on
Netflix
oh my god the cyber the bellhops man
Netflix is like what an HBO special used
to be yeah a Netflix is like the bomb
same day as Full House the new full
house no way oh my god wow that's that's
a big day yeah a day easy to remember by
the way for full house it's now called
fuller house yeah fuller it well done
full house people let's just call it
filler house ah Thank You Joyce we're
gonna play out one of our first times
ever playing steam today we're playing
again called move or die okay
what's up Slayer Darth how's it going
Hanks I don't even know how to say that
Hank 7th of Inc its 1287 dude you got to
get a better name that's awesome hey I'm
awesome what's up so uh the rule is very
simple okay you just move or you die so
hit hit hit a there me a is gonna jump
and you just got to keep running around
there's all these weird little games in
here that it's gonna tell us how to play
okay I wish a lot of these actors that
you wouldn't move or die hit the green
there we go all right and then we just
we just keep playing until we're gonna
kill each other
nice so this one is only back step so we
both have chainsaws okay oh we can only
stab each other in the back oh wow
that's right all right I'm blue you are
yeah hello you yellow yeah so I think
yeah oh my god see this is our buddy
molested I think yeah that's part of the
game is what is my station bond big part
they make part where I lost mine oh you
man the bots well that's just
okay so fought against them well well
it's every one he gets each other but
still let's let's let's no team up
against that let's team up on them for
this epic for this for this for this one
right here yeah all right so what you're
yella alright here we go
let's kill them first and then we'll
kill each other oh there we go got what
Oh
got two of them now it's us
oh god damn it's what you get when you
come on here you're on in the house uh
chilly fall yes it's different rules
every not every round every every match
every man let me get her Vince okay oh
my god
all right no wait our packs oh no I lost
my Pig how I died oh I'm dead I'm
already gonna go still dude oh now it's
just the two bots that was terrible we
pretended we were bad no I think if you
get back over to your breast milk thing
you can oh you think so
yeah you picked up another saw wait hold
on oh wait if I get the song back I
can't jump though it's in the ceiling
yeah you're right maybe not oh man bots
are killing us dude yeah dude this is
bad this is bad news that's a female
bought there one right there yeah I'd
like to see that right dude I'll change
tell us about no wait I have some
questions for you you used to be on the
road rules real world challenge yeah
Road rules of the road rules caste
that's quick what out what is that like
behind that it seems crazy it seems just
like behind the scenes everyone's just
having a great time but then you've got
to battle each other everyday right
yeah it was kind of like this game yeah
I feel like this is yeah this is like
your past and people really brought out
chainsaws yeah well is it like you know
sometimes it's hard for me to remember
it was so long ago but I feel like it
was like I always equated it to like
summer camp Oh like summer camp but like
the dopest summer camp because yeah
everybody was like you know setting up
amazing adventures for you yeah yeah
yeah so like was it a thing where you
would have to play like every single day
no like I would say like about every
three days or four days oh wow I'm kind
of a competition and then you would
travel in between until like a new area
that's crazy my god which should we try
to plug people online yeah wait hold on
here let me see this I don't know which
one that's the power here let's get out
of here um but that's got a fun that
seems oh it was great man I mean you
ended up traveling too traveled across
America trout or in the world and you'd
do crazy games like you would like walk
from like one hot air balloon to another
on like a plank
you know that's insane so you would do
like was there anything that you were
like super afraid to do because they are
all super all really in
there were intense games man they had
one where they put like animal carcasses
into like a woodchip
but like the bit like the greatest wood
chipper ever master woods yeah and it
was shooting like pieces of bone and
meat like about 70 yards and you had to
uh ha you had to wear like this kind of
like like this bucket on your head a lot
double dare if you guys ever double dare
love doll or double dare they remade it
but double dare and you would have to
try and catch things yeah and fill your
bucket up but literally from 70 yards
away like an insane distance and I
remember seeing one girl took a rib eye
off the cheap he's never been the same I
can't believe that uh that she hasn't
sued but cuz that's the crazy thing
about somebody getting hit or hitting a
river and hit by a ribeye and not
knowing they're nuts at 70 they don't
know they're nuts like right a lot of
nuts people really have lawsuits and
they're just not following up on a day's
going bad that's the thing that's why
you got to get the got it through rib
eyes at the craziest people cuz you
never see that anyway they have no idea
yeah that's the thing I mean you know we
could be lawyers I think you and I can
go and they'd be amazing we should
definitely do a class-action suit for
people that have been injured doing
videos actually hurt I sprained my neck
the other day in a skype really so yeah
wait how did that happen what were you
doing mutiny yeah baby I was just kind
of like getting voted it's a dance Skype
it was like I wasn't being like I'm dead
already
don't hit the plot really early this
blocks oh the blocks all I was tearing
through that one again do that really
until my god this is you're battling the
people in the ground the blocks are
falling at the same time it's too if
this it's move or die and also don't get
robots this is like exactly exactly
wait where you from you're from
Louisiana Louisiana yeah that's odd but
you amazingly have the best name I've
ever heard in my life your full name
yeah Theo von kurowsky that's incredible
that is unbelievable like a teacher is
that what is that I think it's like
polish Nicaraguan that is awesome oh my
god or as I call it putting pull pulling
Nick direct if you can't combine those
two pulling it Robbie like we're my
poles at
I'm dead again I remember falling boxes
now when you are so you know
yeah she's mirages yeah she's right
there she's right there with you crazy
you pulled up huh hey all right head yes
this is actually an official thing from
the show I know it seems like it's a
bunch of idiots in a room but this is
actual um I want to say that that's
worldwide what why with the world dude
Netflix is taking over so fill any
Filipino friends out there there we go
get on there February 26 no effects no
offense Theo von watch it also feel
Vaughn calm the oven calm yes you too
around doing standard yeah so around
yeah I'm definitely uh I'm coming up
this summer I'll being like I think's in
different places man I feel like
everybody every everyone every comedian
has like a hell gig story you have like
a like what was like Alito Ohio Toledo
what happened in Toledo uh and honestly
most most comedians would agree on that
uh I just think I honestly feel like I
got uh I might have got rabies you don't
forget already
were you attacked by a pack of dog it's
a it's a man meat of it do you meet a
Toledo you can get rabies from the meat
oh that's sick
did somebody tell you to go to this
place or were you just like this place
looks good I'll wear protection would I
eat meat there now oh yes a that
protection there it a good invention
from telling you face condoms for diners
Oh lawyers we could be patent lawyers it
would his patent are and stuff exactly
let's eat so I'm really having a tough
time on this game right this one this
one is by the way so am i the robots are
killing us this one I think you got to
pass the bomb to somebody else this is
the with the worst game to try to talk
and also there we go oh that's awesome
though what's your favorite what's one
of your favorite places to watch a
performance uh my favorite place to
perform probably New York City I love
Texas anywhere in Texas is good in any
word Chicago Lou Texas who are you a
barbecue fan I'm a barbecue fan even
after
even after the rabbit meeting that yeah
and that's why I was here in the first
place yeah I was like this is tangy for
sure but the tang kind of felt internal
you know it was Tang if I like it was
hanging before once we got ahold of it
you know I wanted to be on your
tombstone
this is tangy for sure I'm already dead
I suck I'm the worst this is tangy for
sure
I'm shooter what's up how's it going
that's ready rush boss - because Theo
von and Erin Blair Chainsaw lawyers
that's a good idea
that's the animated show for sure oh
well dude I used to work on a farm Xu
with a guy for a while what and we had
to cut logs one day uh-huh and he
literally were standing there and this
guy was up he was a little mildly
mentally challenged okay and we all are
but he was you know he was documented
probably should have had a chain table
ibly not but when you were this was like
minimum wage basically this is his basic
rural minimum wage five dollars an hour
got it and he was basically lining up
the chainsaw like on my leg like is he's
like ready to like and I'm like I'm
unhappy where there's like I'm not happy
with this at all like dude that's my leg
and he goes I'm sorry and started doing
his own like it was like that's your
land what's this gasps you know cheese
sauce no and then I left you don't want
to be a witness suffer dude for five
bucks and I'm not getting my leg back I
mean six fifty I would do it six figure
you know I need yeah maybe
80 bucks oh no right yeah 80 bucks an
hour um all right yeah let's pick one of
these pick one of these weird little
mini games this game I'll say this
though this game is uh it's awesome it's
seriously bad to our brains I feel like
it's definitely oh yeah oh you're not
the same after this you know I mean your
kids will blink a lot but it definitely
it's definitely um I could see this
being a blast for like just a couple of
like friends just hanging in Alec Euler
sleep over something you just you know
slumber party saying all night cuz
there's like a hundred different
versions of the game within the game
this would be a good drinking game yeah
this would be a great drinking game oh
yeah because it goes fast and go it goes
fast you want to drink a lot I mean you
would probably die like hour - wait what
is
cleanup crew whoa what's happening here
I had a little broom or something the
problems you can die and don't even know
how I know
I got a Oh No wait what yeah I don't
know cleanup crew what is that you want
to get she wants ten times uh spqr
forever this is called move or die on
Steam and this is called Theo von and I
and what is steam steam is kind of like
the iTunes Store for video games oh wow
so that's like and which is kind of cool
cuz everybody makes these tiny little
games
raaah and then you know if you can
download for like five bucks or
something so this isn't on a net this
isn't on us oh this is Xbox this is well
this is on just a computer playing on
this here we're playing a play on your
computer at home this game yeah oh yeah
oh wow don't enough to have a control a
gamer system I can just have my computer
yeah totally it's awesome it's the
future it's the future and futures now
all we need now are jetpacks so this
week we're trying to paint as much color
on the floor as possible by running over
it oh wow man this is kind of like the
8-bit for now nice if you're one of Tron
the Tron cycle yeah well it's almost
like as if Super Mario as if in each
episode they'd have like where you can
fight each other yeah exactly
it's like Super Mario on steroids yeah
which is awesome so wait now you I was
doing a little research today we're
talking about this earlier crank texts
yeah I came up with this thing where
which is brilliant where you just make
up a phone number yeah I text somebody
and you try to kind of you try to get
something going like a prank tech yeah
and so I I knew the one I the one I read
was the most recent one which was for
Mardi Gras you've got a girl first of
all it explained your strategy explain
your strategy you could you go on these
crazy long adventures with yeah well I
mean it's mind blowing like I I don't I
don't even have those kind of texts with
people I know you know like and you're
just like killing it so how did you
first come up with the idea
okay so crank tech started I got a wrong
I got someone texted me one time from a
wrong number and uh and the text said
hey it's Wanda just so I wrote back
Wanda who sure and she wrote
don't Wanda your cousin yeah now I don't
have any cousins actually both my
parents was only children okay but I'm
not nuts every time but Wanda there's
just no cousins period yeah I'm thinking
holy smokes and maybe I want a cousin
you know maybe this is like a new Obama
cousin program where you get a cousin
you know Obama cousin yeah like a barber
cuts yeah right which would be cool
absolutely does I've always wanted to
cuz um so I wrote back what's up girl
and uh she and I texted for about six
months she thought I was her cousin that
lived in Los Angeles
oh god nephew now named Amar'e
it's gonna be two years old no bike in
March so this is kind of a big time of a
year front family but I'm like holy
smokes this is so cool I'm just gonna
text wrong numbers yeah absolutely so I
took my number in to no 167 and I'm good
and put it in but a nerd oh one six
eight and I were a what's up and
somebody wrote who's this
so then I was made up my name is Daniel
and they're like Daniel so-and-so and I
was like yeah that's great when they
provide the answer correct that's a meat
and a lot of times it doesn't happen I
mean now I'll text I mean I got addicted
I'll text it over probably about 60,000
random note and they're gonna run out of
numbers phone numbers well I got five
heaters going now I got Google Voice so
I can hit people from different area
codes and reason but you can check it
out as cranked XCOM and it's all I mean
there's there's everything yeah really
funny I've been involved in insurance
fraud I've been involved in raising
money for youth militias I've hired
people for Civil War reenactors
sorry church off the Beltway in Houston
yeah man dude I mean yeah you know
people were starting to donate I'm like
this is this I can't accept yeah that's
insane you know that I wouldn't do but
uh and there's been like to think she
was like the the one I saw it's like so
you're like oh she's like who is this
you're like oh it's Lauren it she said
oh my god like Lauren Lyman you're like
yeah and you're like well now now we got
something you ever then Google like the
person that they said to get more info
saathiyaa so like sometimes I do really
getting deep
oh definitely some of those I'll try and
google to see what's going on yes so one
time
oh this will move oh this is terrible
I'm gonna die immediately in this let's
say that one more time kill me yeah wait
a minute says now you can live out your
fancy making our the cousin won't be
weird cuz she's not really your cousin
good point perfect situation
Wow I like your attitude well played
exactly oh my god dad I'm dead I'm dead
but yeah but what were they saying about
they what are you saying about the knife
knife point insurance right
oh no no no about do you ever Google
people yes their name to get more
information well one time I texted it
was a couple of New York I guess
randomly uh-huh I said hey what's going
on I'm raising money for you know we're
buying sod from battlefields around the
world right because rich people avoid
that yeah oh my god it's probably the
fields of Vietnam absolutely apt like
this is from Da Nang I'm you know rocked
it actually hasn't happened yeah like
where'd you get your loan where did you
get your long gone egg exactly you ever
hear of a thing called Gettysburg yeah
but that's actually great Frick in
Gettysburg lon let's do it I wonder if
Gettysburg long calm is taken I
shouldn't even said that cuz now
somebody's bought it um yeah it could be
and so I was like but then all of a
sudden one of them goes machete is this
you
machete and then I'm like how do you
know like you're not welcome here
anymore Cassetti no you're not welcome
here anymore Fischetti we know what you
did the Navy so yeah holding parties and
fundraisers when no one was home all of
a sudden they take me down this rat is
not looking up for Shetty right cuz I'm
supervillain you know
Shetty Oh so that will went on for a
couple of months and it was this older
couple and I never try to like a views
of people like it stuff cuz you don't
want to be mean it's all it's a it is
also all good fun I mean all in good fun
yeah fine yeah it can get dark so you
gotta be there
suppose it gets dark pretty fast
sometimes you can well it can just get
oddly real but they're like who is
texting me they don't that's the other
thing like maybe we need to know these
people
yes exam oh okay I'm just going
door-to-door through my cell phone yeah
you're doing a public service they
should be on a list schottische II
definitely know that jeepers Eddie wait
so how did the Fischetti thing end up oh
the passage anything ended up where I
finally was like well look I'm gonna
apologize for everything and they're
like did you steal you know at Allen's
razor we found his razor and this and
that so I actually went to the store and
bought like a razor and a couple of
other random items oh my god a box and
mailed them to us oh my gosh oh my other
job and I apologize says it's C I
actually helped for Shetty out wait open
they never knew is you is always
Fischetti oh it's all that sauce and I
actually planted a tree I told him I
planted a tree in there they thought I
stole money from it I was like I've
never stolen a I use that tree to use
that money to plant a tree in someone's
name so then I googled a picture of a
random tree haha memorial tree and they
uh so I guess made yeah yeah Bocchetti
osu one yeah he doesn't that one that is
amazing so uh yes sir that's prank text
comment that's great oh yeah that would
make a good I'd make a great show but I
just wonder what it is and if you ever
want to discuss that I'm happy to yes
absolutely
Phish I mean even just for Fischetti
sake to get machete o's like machetes
name out there you know right that's
amazing
oh dude for shy Jewish growing it got
bro he was romancing some of the
neighbor women like I verily this family
left machete comes stay with them
machete like took advantage of these
people and I just so another time this
dude once say he thought I was a girl
first of all every dude you text wants
to bang yeah you're not us we're
disgusting yeah
sorry we're so so we apologize to every
every every woman and some men yes every
dude out there and it's like the story
is great fish a machete oh it's uh I
don't know if the fish anyone is up on
the site but there's not one called um
Indiana gunslinger where a man wanted to
sell me guns and grenades over eastern
Indiana over Easter yeah every stir you
gotta get rid of those got you know for
Jesus obvious weird grenades and katana
slinger will take you to another level
oh that day it was and he's like he's
like you have any tear gas they got a
skier I don't not even joking dude dude
say a picture of them and everything is
like giving us tear gas ladies you know
I have some but I don't want to bring it
over if there's kids inside and he goes
it's okay we have a hose just my dog
here we can rinse his eyes out Oh what
does he need tear gas which is hateful
you should see your friends yeah oh
these are uh these are Sarah Palin books
yeah exactly
I'm also I'm also learned that I lead a
pretty boring life if people are getting
tear gas over text from strangers I mean
to up my like game of just like doing
things in my life oh well do it and
those in Indiana they are doing
everything because they had three people
in total that wanted to meet and
honestly they wanted to meet at schools
usually oh my god oh that's crazy
do you know you could be like the new
Chris Hanson To Catch a Predator so it's
like to catch a crazy in dianion these
are the indianians i love it yeah are
they called indianians yeah indeed
people from Indiana in Michigan is
Michiganders yeah Michigander
Michiganders Indiana Indian ease and
what's it so is do big Indiana is it cuz
you must now have it read as a hotbed
Indiana's hopin you must have your
favorite area code whose whose are
Yorkers are too busy your yeah they're
just like who knew phone who did yeah
New Yorkers are too busy
Indiana later you get a lot of people
that are bat crazy so they'll get
involved
the South you would think we get more
involved but some of the southerners are
weirdly or a weary of snake oil salesmen
oh sure sure that means they've been
duped one too many times you know yeah
exactly
so they hey that's interesting though
that they would be a little more savvy
agree yeah I thought it'd be the other
way around so what is the therapy
Mississippi is they don't count they
don't count as part of America and I
honestly think we should give
Mississippi to Palestine baba world
problem every K because the head of
parity says they're called Hoosiers I
live in Indiana mana parity I fear for
your life if you're living in Indiana
there's a lot of crazy stuff going on in
it yeah there and also I want to just
say this being from the South yeah a lot
of people think we started the KKK no
Indiana day exactly um
now with that said yeah it's a great
time in India yeah you just got to stay
on the main road oh my god you can
donate blood there yeah I wouldn't
receive a pint go go across state wide
go just travel across state lines for
them yeah or just BYOB exactly hey snake
will cook cured my psoriasis and
clubfoot well there you go snake oh yeah
that's why the snake oil salesmen are
out there working it oh that must have
been a strong snake if it clear that
yeah seriously
oh man I hate this one I'm dead already
it's the worst
yeah one more time oh my god absolutely
there's also another game that could
play after this called gang beasts we
just beat each other really yeah let's
do that
there we go gang peace after this steam
is a whole new world we're just getting
on Steve everyone oh my god what is this
a candy time it's a steam is uh apples
gaming it's like no it's by I don't know
who made steam valve it's um some gaming
company but it's basically I can't you
download the app linear computer yeah
and then you just buy games yeah it's
great
and they're weird I played one where I
was like there cuz they're weird right
and fun
I played one where you're a painter
Ruby's just killed a bunch of people and
so paint it with their blood and you
gotta figure out what's going I mean
it's nuts
it's like combining fine art and murder
it's like wow look at good
it sounds very like the jinx with Robert
Durst yeah I never
Jiggs no I want to making a murder
though watch no but the jinx is are you
guys it's a it's so great if the
original original make it a murder yeah
I wrote a top-10 article about the ten
hottest people in making a murder there
we go there we got a week after without
it who's at the top list
oh the top of the list was uh uh
Angeline levy who was the hot reporter I
do remember yeah yeah oh yes and I
actually hit her up I actually her up on
Twitter said she got a couple of
marriage proposals yeah and hit on a lot
whoa the second was the other report of
the male reporter tall guy yeah a silver
hair guy that totally handsome guy
looking sober and after that it was
windy again if it got a little sheepish
right that's combining um but also like
if here's the thing like let's say
you're asking what's your name again and
the levy Angeline lee angel baby you I
don't understand the idea by the
marriage proposal thing there because
then it's like okay let's say she says
yes do you really want to say this is
how we met cuz of making a murder
yeah yeah that seems like a bad yeah
she's probably always gonna think you're
gonna murder yeah right exactly cuz
you're I'm such a fan of making the
murderer yeah I don't know if it yeah
that's weird asses we don't motor Miriam
cuz you have to get to know one right
yeah that's the problem the whole part
where you have a relationship yeah the
relationship part of getting married as
bad oh yeah just got just got dumped
last night what yeah what do you mean
it's got broken up with oh no yeah oh
dude I'm so sorry but single though this
guy it happens there we go oh it happens
that sucks
I know I feel like I have the worst the
were eating luck oh it's the absolute
worst there's one time I am I mean I had
a podcast for two years talking oh nice
yeah
dating yo yeah oh yeah and um like one
time for instance there was this girl
and we were in a car and I was kind of
going in for it to make out her and then
kind of aborted at the last second but
now like my head is moving alongside her
head I'm just gonna end up kissing the
back of the seats and I kind of going I
get her right in the ear right in the
ear she was like oh it was like a wet
willy
yeah awful that's awesome it's just yeah
it's just on and on and on just take
your pick
tough man and this is tough to date and
how's dating out there guys anybody
dating in Indiana what's the EPA India
lissa take like it whatever like it's
yeah this town is hard because the whole
you know it's people don't like people
here be like people and also the county
I do get this feeling everyone kind of
has an agenda you ever get that feeling
what kind of agenda and that's a bummer
when you're on a date and the agenda is
not like let's hook up and the event is
like and if you don't have an agenda you
don't know how to behave to make people
it's hard act like you don't have an
engine yes you're right yeah you're like
I got stuff going on yeah and I think
you just want to try and be friends with
somebody but everybody yeah it's tough
yeah exactly
we're complaining today guys that [ __ ] I
went on a date with this girl who is
like an actress she shows up a lot of
plastic surgery first of all Wow 28mm
lot of plastic surgery 428 which by the
way is any plastic surgery 428 yeah
shows up for dinner 35 minutes late no
tanks or anything do we respond shows up
she's like oh I've already eaten like
okay do you mind if I eat you no go
ahead I'm like great so now I'm eating
at the end it was just like terrible she
looked like kind of like Jack Nicholson
as the Joker you know what the things
yeah I loved him in there he was great
not a good I wouldn't date him right but
and then at the end she was like I was
like like did you you know did you
valley she's a good I felt later like oh
I'll just walk you to the valet stand
which is 10 feet I couldn't wait to get
away from this girl and then she also
tried to make fun of the waitress who
was really nice oh that's a word I was
just like I was not playing that game
and then she's like cool take care of
this and I was like why the ballet
valley thinking I was like you know what
it's worth the five bucks to never yeah
that's the other guy oh god it's the
worst she hated dogs who hates dogs yeah
dogs are good they're good animals yeah
whoo hey Tommy I don't know if the worst
but she told me all about her problems
and her projects and stuff so that was
fun
all right wait should we switch games
let's write every game let's try the
ninja game up we're gonna change it up I
think now wait do you want to try now we
have two two options here maybe we let
the people decide gang beasts or keep
talking and everywhere everybody except
last me okay let's try gang beasts let's
try it gang beasts gang beasts right
beasts yes please
this is gonna be fun so yeah this is
steam here this is it this is it you're
seeing the guts of steam oh wow
yong-ki I'm cured about this steam I
gotta get steam at the house you know I
gotta get more pristine oh yeah okay
stuff gets so dirty when you do it you
do a thing you don't realize that your
carpet gets hella dirty feel lonely yeah
which I am yeah it's hella crazy people
beating each other yeah this is
literally just beating each other at Fox
News this is Fox News the game this is
Fox News you know I don't I've only
played this like twice so let's go let's
see how this works your survival we're
gonna go love this old it's like an old
school strange game also this could
crash at any moment which is that's the
other fun thing about steam as you just
never know you never know yeah I could
die it could crash any moment but you
know what that's that's the so we're
gonna all right here started from game
rooms
III that would be amazing I mean me I
don't know probably I think on like they
have those MMO RGS or like people go on
like Star Wars online it's a thousands
of people playing I think people have
met each other and in there yeah my
friend Tony Tony it is one time this is
a true story by the way at work I miss
co-workers just like this is like 10 or
12 years ago was like I was talking
about her vacation she's gonna go home
with her boyfriend she's super excited
okay here it is this is it let me
practice room in about myself okay yeah
wait come and beat me yeah I think this
is yeah I don't actually know how to
play this oh my god you can jump oh we
need to do that mapping thing I'm Ally
for this you can headbutt oh maybe oh
wait no you know what I think it works
like yeah you could you know I think you
could punch with these oh I can also
dance look at me dance oh you could whip
and nae nae a little
yeah I mean uh well yeah whoo I don't
think my yakking
oh wait trying to try the triggers there
we go I think that's a punch is like a
dress let's go look at your stepdad Wow
dude real fights are like this I'd watch
I'd want everybody to fight crazy this
is exactly how I fight oh no no I think
we how do we are we trying to knock you
down I push each other off yes Wow so he
caught the number eight Wow quit it son
oh my god oh my god Wow the gay just
gave up Oh perfect dude we got to do
that again I hate it hates it it hates
me let's see here Oh guys you got to
play this one give and played this what
hey gang beasts gang gang gang beasts it
is very this is not where you want to
meet a woman or a man this is not where
you want to be this is not let's try a
different stage what do you think god
you want to go trucks we like trucks
my trucks dude everybody likes trucks
especially to fight among there we go
all right I'm gonna be you know I didn't
think that the wrestler in do me well
there hit a hit a all right I'm gonna go
I want you know trucks trucker I'm gonna
be this juggling it don't look at that
look at that come over maybe the straw
look at that cohort so I'll be on the
comb like any other hey thanks missing a
lot of ground work a lot of color Wow
this one oh I get it
get it with the head foot Oh oh yeah oh
that's bad I'll kill myself
Oh
oh that's not ro this is grabby design
but people are doing this oh it's all oh
oh oh when he goes uncheck that
comb-over dude it's intimidating I'm not
gonna like this because I meant oh here
we go now it's on because a guy a guy
who could just rock that come over just
doesn't care about life oh he's just
like I will take you oh my god named
that he is he was a little bit ahead
brah Rosie I can't believe you guys do
this is great I know man you gotta get
on the swing
do you all let me just beat you punch
him in the head dude
this is the of the lotta I'm tired baby
I'm doing yeah all right of it yeah uh I
came I'll just straight minion game yo I
can't stay on the truck dude dream is
scary this game is awful this game is
scary killing me 31 you gotta get so we
do this is twitch you gotta get it man
how did you get a twitch account oh you
gotta get twitch accounts awesome it's
the new thing that's new thing so how do
I do that tell me if I'm great it's
great just twitch get online twitch
yeah twitch TV sign up and then you just
stream video you already got video games
you don't know my computer via a
computer easy peasy
alright trucks was not my thing I need a
place you can really get to know one
here we go yeah not doing dare
incinerator I say we go let's go three
lives yeah oops
all right it's on no mate can we play
with people online I don't know it's
Erin Blair yeah it's Erin blur
oh you know what I'm dressing up for
this one okay you go it's respect I'm
going to work like that oh the bear
bring the bear you at the water cool
we are ready yeah at the water go just
joining us with Theo von today after
communion you can see his Netflix
special no offense
dropping February 26 the same day fuller
house comes on yep February 26 you said
it's a little offensive it's all in jest
though so don't come in there and get
all yes it's comedy yo we're having a
good time comedy oh that's right check
out Theo von calm and me just busting up
these windows
oh look at this
this bear versus our have you ever seen
that I am out just this is what happens
when you don't put your food in the bear
that's right now what's up now it's I'm
gonna punch you this window oh no it
died yes this game kill it me there we
go start it look what is interesting
though is that the game can be like I'm
out yeah the games like nope nope I'm
gonna use that I mean I'm going chicken
this time I'm using I'm using this
restart as a way yes all right dude I'm
going with uh-oh I'm going with the
LeBron after a game you're going
press-conference LaRon fresco run right
here son
no wait did you watch the Super Bowl
yeah I did did you do you have any money
on the game or anything I did it man I
lost enough money here in the season we
put my friends in order to stay out of
this one nice who'd you cheer for I it
was tough I wanted Payton hey yeah yeah
you know it's like I figure cam and the
Panthers will be back you know he's a
young team and it's cool that it would
it's cool to see Payton like I'm not
even a sports fan but right you feel
like you the guy deserves it you know
the story the story yeah exactly
um who's burning what factory is this
where they're burning up just boxes I
know this probably it's kind of Ko I
gotta yeah this is yeah this is exactly
what happens in our office I'm going you
know what I'm a chicken I'm going head
butt head bought it no eggs out of it oh
I heard this morning pack and friend
pack him to death in New Orleans that
Archie and pay like they're trying to
put together a group to buy the Saints
whoa dude that would be insane so
Peyton's dad who played for the Saints
and then yeah Eli you grew up there oh
that would be awesome I think it could
be a good GM cuz maybe nose talent you
know oh yeah he's a hard worker I feel
like you know Cindy is like Elway you
know no way it's like it these oh this
now is like just a I gotta get over
there wait can i I gotta throw you in
the fire how do we kind
huh my stylist oh yeah get it get it
throw me the thing throw them in the
thing how do I get there I'm in two
phases don't get up get him in the fire
all right now I think you're blowing oh
there we go
Oh No get up oh yeah no trading the
chick Wow straight to the fire with the
chicken Wow
that roasted roasted balloons not
worried boom stop working I love the
beach you had it beat down there's like
the end I wasn't that was a beat down in
the half this is good as he ran high on
life or is this not the survive ah no
I'm not cocaine I've done a lot of
cocaine this morning yeah it's that kind
of morning yeah you know it's a Monday
cocaine mornings gain Monday cocaine
exactly get out of bed son go oh yeah
sheets way too comfortable than anybody
else notice I agree with that you know
the thing is like they say you spend
half your life on your back so you
should invest in a comfortable bed I say
that brings my productivity down yeah
you know we're talking about in Russia
the Stone dolls it's play with stone
dolls don't dolls in Russia now that
makes them hard oh you know it makes
them tough little we had a lugging 11
pound doll in a bed at night oh my god
just a little kid just like dragging a
doll yeah it's true but that makes you
talk me I think you know make your bed
uncomfortable yeah pop right out of bed
oh here we go look at me I'm just
staring into the flames thinking about
the choices I've made my life this is
what about done here let's go yeah
oh man the spot the spot I the head
buddy's like my move I think just like
wrong this is like behind the scenes at
Comic you know I wanted to be in the
guardians of the galaxy panel this is
exactly how fights happen at comic-con
oh geez we don't joke please don't joke
oh whoa you just tossed me around like a
rag doll apparently we both are only
right-handed yeah yeah exactly
oh I'm just taking a look Foxy's take
Napa Roo thing on that I'll back though
oh I got him
know who's got who yeah oh my god hell
yeah what's up nomadic that's right
we're on Twitch
we're on twitch and playing gang beasts
at Theo von today Wow yeah we're playing
playboy get in here Miley Cyrus spends
more than half her life on her back why
does she sleep a lot understand the joke
I don't get it I guess she's spina maybe
like a spinal issue yeah she has maybe
she's like that problems man lumbar a
lumbar issues you could like it can seem
like it cuz she instead of having a
wheelchair almost here like riding on
the top of a car and on that wrecking
ball yeah she can't even walk yeah the
wrecking ball video could have messed
her up yeah is if you come in like a
wreck if you come in like a wrecking
ball you're bound to hurt your back yeah
dude wrecking balls feel pain very
archaic with just punching you the back
of just camping look oh look at this
dude the slow huh oh look do you see my
eyes oh look at that I just came back up
like a demon eyes oh yeah oh yeah I love
this game is oh like oh not just both
out yeah this is insane huh that's right
do a barrel roll I'm trying literally
can hear of yeah yeah
look at this Wow can I did make you chew
on this conveyor belt over here yeah
that's the move this is like do you feel
this I feel like this is easy this just
might be the best game ever made no no
no no no I gotta throw this freak in the
fire huh I'm out I'm just sleeping just
get over here I love what he wakes up
his eyes open alright it's on now this
is also hi dance
I'm the desiccant cat if I jump around
you can't really catch me oh wait so
let's talk about no offense okay no no
special February 26 Netflix ah Netflix
and it's more free-range like my
comedies not as like much like telling
like jokes as much as it is just being
myself
Oh awesome and I just share in stories
man and how long did it take for you to
put together the set took about 12 years
that's awesome so this is uh oh there we
go this is a good stuff
crap we shot it down in New Orleans
oh sweet yeah town hometown shot it down
there which was nice are you from
actually New Orleans or somewhere in
Louisiana from the suburbs so go to
Covington Lousiana whoo I love by the
way I can't believe you're not a
thousand pounds cuz the food down there
is so good yeah Lee I'll go down there a
couple times here to eat I literally met
him the other day was like yeah we fly
to louisiana every year just we bring
our own silverware you know my wife got
a new spoon we're looking to try out in
Vegas that wasn't a Craig test yeah that
was real good rinse yeah good riddance
uh so yeah we shot it down there and uh
it was fun made a lot of friends and
family came out some people had never
been to a comedy show before they didn't
how to behave what do you mean some
people thought it was like a football
game like they were like cheering the
whole time like Oh have somebody's
yelling defense exactly that's not the
same we want a picture got a belly
itcher you're like get out get out
we're like put in the backup please lady
mom don't you support me
it's crazy were you nervous doing
because like the thing is like I feel
like any time you perform like this for
instance like it's like things are live
and it's fine I guess this is recorded
but you know what I'm saying like if you
have a bad night at a club okay you just
have a bad night and it kind of doesn't
live you know right musicians have said
a lot of times they get actually more
nervous doing their album because that's
then going to be you know enjoyed I see
there yeah that's there yeah I was
definitely nervous man you get two shots
how do you tape
in the night oh cool so at least you get
a second shot oh that's cool I think and
combine them if need be right yeah and
they'll mix them up and stuff but it
definitely did you have a mustache in
the second taping now we can't cut it in
just like you do your mustache appears
it can be nerve-wracking that's crazy
that's awesome though it can be
nerve-wracking but I thought it was cool
just because like a lot of my friends a
family had never been in like a big
comedy show like to a television taping
is that it's a whole different energy in
the television tape yeah I mean it's
excitement I mean people are excited and
they you know they want you to succeed
it was a couple times where I flub some
lines and I like really needed like the
audience and they all started cheering
and stuff so like there was some moments
where yeah that's dope dude this is cool
this is really really but yeah so but
here's a question so if you flop a line
can you just do the joke again yeah
let's stop and start a be like guys okay
with me because if sometimes I was so
nervous at one point I was like
stuttering yeah like I couldn't get the
line out I was like I got to get this
line out and then every sort of clap and
I knew that I could just kind of start
back from where I was that's awesome
yeah that's the thing is like I feel
like it is a whole different lips it's a
whole different game than actually just
performing just normally I am yeah cuz
in a club there's not a ton of pressure
yeah if you do good you do bad I mean
there's never usually a video camera on
you so it's over once you do it yeah
that's crazy man but um Netflix that's
huge I know it's just like Netflix is
like killing it these days that's
exactly where you want to be you know
yeah I mean I definitely feel really
excited I'm just grateful that they give
me this opportunity cuz it's a long road
it's mostly coming from out of like
being a reality TV kid like it's family
and comedy you can't fake it up there
you can't get up there and like you know
what is this room what is this room oh
oh give me out ah who's on the grinder
shirt matches your head in your pants
match your heads back the well to work
what'd I tell you about where that's a
word just called a sickie or a straight
down you know you think you know
I'm just punching you ah good and really
sick of you Danny I want to add you to
my professional network get back here
download the mobile strike app now I
can't live with you oh you just want to
have your chicken out oh oh I've ended I
can't take you anywhere in the face
without Peter getting upset look right
in there Britain the jeepers oh yeah you
is there is there it's big of either a
line TV kid is is there do you feel
pressure or did you feel pressure
escaping that world oh yeah for years
yeah
for years those things you couldn't do
yeah cuz it's like you're out of it now
but it seems like a lot of people don't
get out of it which is tough yeah it's
tough and it was at a weird time when
that was like there was not a way really
to transfer as much that's true that's
your absolute last yellow mashed oh oh
that's that's um but a couple people of
you know transcended out of that into
like different types of entertainment
like um is I don't you guys have had the
MS yeah yeah yeah yeah this is great
um and I think it's good yeah it's you
just send us she's an actress and to
Barrett isn't it yep yeah Jamie Chung
but you're young when that happens you
don't know what you want out of your
life I mean I wanted to be a stand-up
comedian really at that point that's
yeah of course
so that's kind of like in yeah now
you're kind of shot to superstardom and
then you're kind of like oh wait I
should have some sort of a plan or
something yeah and like you would then
you look back when I wasn't at a college
campus and they were like who wants to
go on a trip around the world away oh my
god that's crazy crazy stuff that's
amazing oh yeah there we go get him Oh
jeepers dude huh
I'm following a report oh look at this
office rage Oh take my stapler thank you
so much yeah oh no no I'm in the grinder
the jumpring I am NOT your buddy eat
only cake in the break room like this
Hey and quit hiding my seed in your baby
oh you want you uh
stronger than good chicken I'm not
stronger than a chicken apparently I'm
getting dragged by you
Wow
now you know what your dad does it work
all day guys oh here we go it's pretty
I'm coming in hot this time Wow music
the kicking is not barely kicks things
are I thought it was dressed down fine
I'll show you casual Friday
Wow that you won no you take it down
because you get to you take it down yeah
take it down finally all right you wanna
play a little don't stop talking about
mcsweats all right I gotta I gotta move
some things around
I'm nervous but I'm excited all right
all right all right all right
hello jingis 860 hello Angus how are you
that's right just hold it down for Aaron
and you were just keeping it real in
here keeping it real that's right now um
it was an intense game it was good that
was an intense game that was a fun dad
Gabe it's though all right so here's how
we're gonna do this so to do this we're
going to you got a switch with that okay
all right wait do you want to be the
diffuser will switch off first you want
to read the manual or you want to be the
diffuser I will read the manual okay
all right perfect all right so you guys
[Music]
explodes all right that's right
everybody nervous yeah you should be
nervous
you should mean there this is this is
nerve-racking this is nerve-racking I've
never done anything like this yes that
iPad right there all right so this game
involves we need to go to a website to
see the manual feels gonna read the
manual here's the thing you can't see
the bomb and I can't see the man right
so communication we just gotta
communicate all right - chainsaw lawyers
back back back and I think we have a
time limit and the bomb is has a bunch
of crazy stuff you can't see the bomb
and I can't see the manual i I can't
you're gonna read the manual I can't you
can't see what I'm looking at okay and
I'm in there like I like to think about
this Hurt Locker I'm in it I'm Jeremy
runner you're Anthony Mackie
what kind of the truck you know what I'm
saying and not accurately exactly two
brothers second few as making sure I got
my link put up correctly because my
friends are checking this out
hell yeah here we go so notification
code two-for-one I'm gonna turn this off
okay here we go
all right okay here we go guys I'm gonna
try not to explode things but it could
happen they could happen cuz I'm
terrible at this hold on the first bomb
sorry just got put this code in here too
for yep dude this screen is for my eyes
only so let's see you hold this I'll
hold this yep and then I read off there
let's see 241 is the thing okay okay
here we go
can you can you read the manual yeah all
right here's what we're looking at we're
looking at I've got let's see - white
I've got four wires - or white one is
red one is blue there's a button that
says press on it there's four there's a
keypad before things on it one is like a
backwards Crescent one's a cue one's a
loop and one's enough set up a question
mark okay if there is more than one red
wire you have four wires right yeah well
the one is red only one is more than
woke a otherwise if the last wire is
yellow no it's blue laughs where's blue
it's you white white red blue okay um
for why if there's more than a but if
there's exactly one blue wire yes okay
cut the first wire cut the first wire
yes okay cut all right we're good we're
good also
top it looks like there's like a red
plug and a white plug and a green plug
and a top and there's like a there's
like a Jesus Christ okay
otherwise if there's more than one
yellow wire no yelling no there's no
yellow wire no yellow I'll go down to
three wires
yeah we're only on three wives there's
also on the bottom there's two double-a
batteries there's a pink slot is the
last wild white the last word is blue
okay and okay let's see here and the
bottom has the last wire cut the last
wire yeah
no no that was wrong that was wrong we
had it was yeah we have we got a strike
okay all right so the bottom let's see
we gets three strikes the bottom has a
pink slot when you plug a cord into at a
blue slot you plant corn into on the
subject of the keypads oh Jesus and
there's there's a to battery there's
three batteries on the side eggs are the
keypads yes on the keypads
yeah the keypads there's a a queue a
backwards crescent okay I'm set on
question mark and like a loop like a
curly Q okay I press those press all of
them no wait on the public you only one
caller was all for this one key press
the four buttons are they so okay I
don't know
oh wait green light means it's done oh
if it's green you're done with the
module oh wait that might be a no that
wasn't right what happened I don't know
I press the thing and there's a second
strike how many wires are the left I
mean there's a there's only need a
couple of wires what do we need I don't
know I'm not sure what does the manual
say oh don't like each like if the
button is blue and the button says abort
no it says press the button says press
okay um is there anything else we need
to do I feel like it's still counting
down um let me see a why are mods I can
only have three six wires on it only the
one correct wire needs to be cut to the
song tomorrow light was not green on up
with that section okay oh I see I see I
got it wrong all right now the keypad
situation okay I'm screwing this up
alright so the four things are there's a
queue mm-hmm
there's a see that's backwards with a
dot from an upside down question mark
impairment and a loop-d-loop okay so
which one of this do i press press the
four ones in the order
we'll hear from the top about okay so
it's a which one is it first okay so if
there's so the on the top left is a
backward see top right is like a cue or
like a spyglass bottom left is upside a
question mark bottom right is a
loop-de-loop
um Oh God bottom right is a nope no
what's the second one the second one is
that I like a cue or like a
looking-glass
that's cue I would go with the
looking-glass Looking Glass yeah okay
now do it
it's been doing it now do I it's green
do I press another one I would press
another word backwards see backward see
ya do it good good what's the next one I
press okay um or the other - the other
two is a loop-de-loop an upside on a
question mark um let's do the looky-loo
yep yes and now let's try press it to be
blow every when the game yeah oh damn it
wait that's my I screwed that up
because I didn't realize we had to get
all of them all the modules done I don't
realize you had to get all the modules
that no tents the directions is hard man
true try again oh yeah alright one more
time try again then we'll switch so part
is welcome too dangerous and challenging
world of bomb defusing study the manual
carefully you are the expert that means
I'm the expert these pages you will find
everything you need to know to defuse
even the most insidious of bombs and
remember one small oversight it could
all be over okay
okay here we go alright so now okay core
okay we've got out three wires from top
to bottom it's black white white okay
have three wires from top to bottom
black white white okay if there are no
red wires cut the second wire cut the
second wire boom got it
okay now another next thing the keypad
okay there's like an Omega symbol
there's like a backwards end with like
antlers there's a I guess it's like a
Euro sign one column is all for the
symbols from the keypad there's one that
looks like a like a hash mark kind of
okay one that is a hash mark well it's
kind it's like a it's like a it's like a
half of the hash mark it's like it looks
like it's like it's like the
kind of looks like this okay that looked
a little vial
second of all um get me describe the
easiest one to me what's the easiest one
is looks like a three dots above it okay
okay okay I see that one and give me one
more do you have one that looks like
kind of like a UH a bit of like the
Jewish Christmas symbol a little bit no
no there's there's like a backwards n
okay backwards an okay good okay good
okay okay so do you have like a one
looks kind of like a six one looks kind
of like a six no okay then the first one
you want to push is the backwards Eve
with the two dots above it okay boom
green K on it do you have like a train
track yes yes a train track yeah or a
train track boom yeah that's great okay
there you have an AE + AE no no there's
a backward no that was in and then
there's the Omega C Omega C will you AK
words in boo mega boom yes
alright and wait now what do we do I
just press the thing now what y'all the
subject assignment says is the red blue
flashing stuff
red blue flashing stuff I don't see any
red blue flashing stuff what's going on
now there's okay at the top is like a D
battery with some like a red button or
red like a slot in a green slot and a
phone cord place to put a phone cord the
side has another D battery with a little
green place to put in a cord on the
bottom has two double-a batteries I
don't know if some of them have to do I
don't know do I check one of the four
color buttons will flash wait a four
color button what no there's no it's net
you know there's no four color bunch I
just try pressing and holding the thing
there's there's that there's one there's
a big button that says Pratt that says
hold a big subject to the button big
yellow but if the okay if the button is
blue and the button says abort
hold the button and refer to releasing a
help but it's yellow and it says hold
okay if the button is yellow hold the
button and refer to releasing a help
button
okay well that's fun a white of pulsing
light is on release when the countdown
timer has a five in any position okay
2006
five released it oh oh wait let me try
let me try again I'm holding it now it's
a yellow pulsing light is that bad
yellow pulsing is a yellow button it
says hold and a yellow pulsing light
okay let me say uh it's a yellow but
pulsing if the bunnies yellow hold the
button it refer to releasing a held
button okay you not release the
countdown when the countdown is a yellow
strip yeah yellow strip you got a
countdown timer as a 5 in any position 5
any position okay we go 6 5 did it
already we did it okay I think that's it
no it can't be it what else we have to
do wait I mean we did it we did it we
did it yeah we did it nice that was
great oh my god very nerve-wracking oh
my god all right you want to see where
who's oh my god that's really
nerve-racking everyone on the chat
whether I'm staring the chat it's just
like push the button hold the button
push the but at least the button just
like okay wait so here let me put up and
what's our stream again so I can put it
into mine it's a twist on TV /team coca
okay perfect yeah it starts you off easy
it gets harder death night says yeah we
did it got it was good mom's gonna do
husband abuse all right now we're gonna
switch okay okay so now here so here's
kind of how it works basically if the
right if you press and hold the right
the right mouse button okay I kind of
let you look around yeah and then you
kind of click into a section and then
what's that section selected then you
can do stuff in it so yeah Beth knows
what I love this about this is hurt me
get like good starting to get really
yeah all right here we go here we go
thank you think I'm nervous man I'm
nervous all right so the mouse click
start there okay
click start okay oh my god there's so
many words yeah holy crap okay okay we
got start
all right so Darton the screen is your
eyes only you're not allowed to look at
the bomb different angle I'm not a lot
of looking yep right okay here we go oh
there's so many symbols okay here we go
this bump says five minutes on it all
right here we go so yeah all right then
pick up the bomb with the left the left
button and click on the button and then
you can click on the little there's like
little sections you see okay so talk to
me what do we got we got this uh this
Simon Says type area okay
okay Simon say
looks like Roman says it's like red blue
yellow and green ok linking yellow on
the subject of Simon Says if it's
blinking yellow one of the more color
bugs without using the cursor below okay
it's blazing yellow the corresponding
color blinking yellow blinking yellow is
a green hit green ok blinking yellow so
I'm gonna hit green green all right i'ma
hit green green okay perfect did they do
the hex of like a double yellow double
yellow oh my god ah like a double yellow
double four minutes left blinking double
yellow wouldn't save one I mean - yes mm
yeah yeah I guess we have no strikes so
I guess we already hit green right yet
is it safe it's looking twice over do
repeat the seek wait using the correct
impressed by the corresponding the
original button will flash followed by
another repeat this sequence in order to
use the color mapping okay
one two okay a double green them okay
all we got one two okay now we got two
yellows in the green okay try not try
that but I can't do two yells in the
green because oh I hit green again or
what is it what is green it said Green
says Green says you hit yellow okay this
old one it says to see what the lengthen
by one each time you correctly under
sequence so yeah alright next next
section alright let's go to the the
abort button
okay the abort button the abort button
on the central button
okay yellow abort the button is the
button in yellow abort button it says
abort a button is yellow of the button
or three minutes left okay okay so hold
the button okay hold the button hold the
button and then let's see releasing hell
button yeah what's color is the strip
the strip is blue the strip is blue
released when the countdown timer has a
four in any position okay the bone we
got it boom nice alright now we're on to
the the the signals the Alpha signals
the look the keypad keypad yeah the
signals okay okay so we have an int we
have like that in that upside down in
with the antlers yeah that's six
okay got it we have the
we have they looks like a the Hebrew
symbol with the candles almost kind of
yeah yeah yeah it's like a pitchfork yes
and then we have the Omega symbol okay
okay great
only one column is all for this is from
the keypad press the four button they
were sailors before demo Nikon okay sexy
said we are druid peak good machine we
going oh yes okay I hit the six okay six
and then you said at the end we got the
candelabra okay Omega that Oh with the
horseshoe okay hit the the candelabra
the pitchfork okay then hit the end and
hit the Omega boom boom
what happened that's good all right any
more sections is there anything that's
it that's it we did it we did it dude
awesome it's a little bit harder with
two minute left we did it there's crazy
I said we go a little bit harder on yeah
what do you think do we do f initely
dude do we do it yeah it's definitely I
gotta say there are so many words on
this manual look at this this is just
like crazy and there's like 40 pages
there's like it's like you can see its
extensive its extensive and
nerve-racking for sure like if it were a
real bomb this manual would not apply at
all
exactly alright here we go we ready for
this three minutes can we do it yeah we
can death are you ready yeah all right
you want to read you comfortable here
good runner all right Jeremy right
really you got a good regenerate Jamie
run a little backup okay back up here we
go baby go all right we're starting we
got three minutes here let's do it
always go hard and never go solve yes so
I'm trying to do I love it alright here
we go
we got our bomb we got our bomb we got
three minutes on this thing okay I'm
ready I'm just page it through the
manual load not only crap later three
minutes three modules three strikes up
time Morse code we to mount Morse code
could beat us here we go 254 left okay
uh we have a number pad it looks like
numbers and there's one number in a box
no a number pad or the symbol pad again
oh let's get a simple pad this symbol
pad here so let's start with symbol per
mo pad yeah okay symbol pad this symbol
has the six okay six got it it also has
like an it looks like an L beam and one
thing like a long beach looks like a
sword with like a be okay
like a cross kind of with like a big
capital B yep yep we also have one looks
like a spider and some dude trying to
like choke a spider oh yes I got it okay
okay um and then we have one that looks
like two K's back to back okay cool
all right so I'll do six okay be guy
choking guy choking a spider hmm - case
boom we got that done okay now we're
gonna go should be professional bomb
defusing very good okay and chainsaw you
try first all right here we come okay so
now we're at this color this this number
pad no no it looks like there's no more
numbers a sequence looks like it through
some type of a sudden we all the word
pad yeah remember something sequential
maze there's no maze right all right
passwords number a number pad a number
is complicated and then there's one that
has a mate that has like a triangle
going in a circle with like some green a
triangle going in a circle would about
is called choking a spider so here's a
twelve-inch penis that's intense
Wow god help me God helping do got a
minute to have a number a number pad
there's just noise like a it's just a
sequence oh I see okay okay I'm sorry
memory that's the correct blend
amendment of it what are the numbers 1
and then I'm 1 4 2 3 and there's a 4 in
the Box up above oh there's a 4 up in
the Box up above okay displays displays
for its place for display is 4 so a
minute left
oh my god let's see if the display is
for press the button in the same way
stage 2 stage 1 display is for press the
button in the fourth position press I'm
sorry
alright stage - if display is 3 + but in
the first position ok this plays - are
do then press the button the same label
you pressed the very first time okay so
the fourth position again yes okay boom
all right well that display is 1 1 in
same position you pressed again in this
first stage Wow oh no it's a no [ __ ] ah
let's see we use a now two three no two
three so please no first the first
button now first button first one is
three third position okay boom got it
what is it now now it is
one one label for 4k okay mm-hmm no it's
a to to say the same thing in stage one
okay oh [ __ ] sorry no problem
missed it no problem
damn it I want every penny met I didn't
know it's hard to see what the different
modules are on here listen to the
listener this guy how excuses is I can't
read this is how we find out I can't
read that be the best for like
everything like if you're in heaven a
muse like like kind of be like a bro
about it dude they were like yeah you
know what it's only has one arm like oh
man the floors were slippery floors this
is sleep I want to rematch on this one I
I want a rematch if you'll retry there I
think
all right retry let's do it yeah I think
we gotta try one more try there's
different modules on here it's crazy all
right here we go all right here we go
all right three minutes left or let's
start with our sign thing another Omega
and all that okay yeah insignias okay so
you got the C facing the backwards with
a dot in the middle got it got the
spider choke getting choked out by the
man okay you have like that symbol
that's on Harry Potter's forehead yep
and then you have a pyramid with two
blocks at the bottom and one at the top
pyramids like an A with a penis got it
first hit the a with the penis boom
Harry Potter symbol of choking spider
the sea choking spider Hidden Dragon
alright we got that one boom okay so now
let's go to it has words like right
blank press middle weight left got it
okay and then it is you in the top on
the on the display okay so you is in the
top of the display let's see here
you and now hit sure sure
sure isn't an option [ __ ] wait okay
anyway say what it is again you is at
the top and the display well we're using
the label from step one oh this is step
two oh whoops oh yeah oh my god okay you
is in the use in the display and we have
right left blank wait press middle as a
button you okay so it's right in the
middle right middle right right wasn't
it okay we display and now the display
says yes now that says yes okay yes okay
and a half left read the label of a
particular button and proceed to step
two
okay it says what the hell use the
button label oh my god okay I'm okay
okay read the display and you step one
determine which button to read okay I'm
reading so yes
oh I see okay so what what what does it
say on the left second position what's
less press okay so then here we go to
press press press press
now hit right varieties in an option god
damn it
what don't hit the right side of that
column baby okay it says yes right so
I'm looking at the thing cuz well 45
seconds Oh God button Lee will you step
to determine which button to push okay
so it's blown ah I know
alright huh it's so from the Left column
from the top down what are the things
that yes press wait yes press and wait
okay and the top one says yes yes hey
yeah wait the top one across the top
says yes yes okay so yeah so it's it's
press is on here press is the one also
press middle okay I do that way okay
good the right side of the press one
okay now it's red no it
that thing is red no red is in this play
Oh red to display got it red red red red
red we read or read blue
let's wait let's realize when it's whit
and this is the then maybe you're better
reader this is we have time for one more
bomb I don't have any lambs left oh my
god your toes use your television ice
this is really hard and I'm terrible
game dead uh but guys these Direction
really are insane they are gonna say
yeah exactly CVX 14 the X 14 has played
this before it because that's the name
of the section it's called who's on firm
Oh confused blaze confused that's two
certainly done all right get ready all
right let's do it
okay this is it last bomb we got this we
got this
you ready three minutes on the clock and
go
okay we have a number thing there's a -
up top okay and then three two for one
it looks like the memory I got a number
thing with two up top yep so - yeah he
was up top okay if okay two is up top
yes play is stage one of the display is
to press the button in the second
position the second position done got a
next one one is up top one is up top
press a button labeled four okay done
next one three is up top okay if three
is up top press the button in the third
position okay
boom good should post it shouldn't say
boom one is up top one is up top press
the button in the same position as you
press in stage one got it okay and last
one for is up top uh
press of off with the same label you
pressed in stage three it's that four oh
no all right start over crap alright
what is up top one is up top press the
button the second position okay got it
now three is up top three is up top
press the button in the first position
okay good kid
now one is up top one of the top press
of up with the same level you pressed in
stage two say label first position yep
got it
okay I'm gonna bracket four is up top
boar's up press the button in the same
position as you press the stage - that's
just a second position yeah no that was
wrong it says floors of top floors up
top we got a minute 14 where's the time
here we go okay let's get it here we go
all right four is up top press up on the
fourth position boom got it now four is
up top press the same button is pressed
in stage one same one so that fourth is
got it
phors up top again press the button
labeled for perfect so so far it's last
last for one is up top press the button
the same position you press in stage one
got it okay to press the ball with the
same label you press the states - no I
wasn't it oh it was the first one yeah
we're dead alright one more
this is the last time we can't go out on
a boob we can't go out in a boom we're
dead okay that was my fault okay man I
think we're finding the weak link is me
here Theo is great I don't know I'm you
should be in the truck I I deserve to
get blown up
alright I'll look if you want to get out
there I'll stay with six inches all
right here we go okay here we go let's
do it let's do it okay okay I'm looking
at a thing let's do it says see up top
and then it's like aha
sure you are it's I think it's the chart
with the eyes okay okay so see E's up
top okay Cee is up top so if C is up top
then you're gonna want to do the one in
the bottom right position bottom right
is your got it okay okay yep and now
hold on as a bottom right position again
no this is wrong really alright lead is
up time led Oh Oh step - sorry lead is
up top
come latterly led led okay so lead is up
top and then it's bottom left position
catalyst Oh No is this step one or two
that was step one that was step one no
it's step two 1step2 1step2 or on six
yeah you are as up top your walk your
you are so what uh you're next like uh
huh what done that again
you're next like uh huh
what done that's not all of the uh huh
hold you letter you your work now sure
war nope you are you are I don't thinks
I wait I have this step two or three I
think this is step two cuz we have a
green light
okay
so okay so it I'm seeing from a top left
down hold
aha next then right column you are sure
done you are whole next sure you are so
if yours up top what's the position of
the I if you were how do you spell you
you you are just the letters you okay
what's the system all right it doesn't
have the I because then it just goes to
the words okay okay okay so the words
are what what's the first word they're
just put the bug on your bottom right
bottom right right right we only had 12
seconds so here's a promise when you get
to this part of the make like I know I
can't figure that out either push the
first button that appears in its
corresponding list oh all right this is
the a baby says baby you got a different
fob to defuse it yeah a pooh-bah there
we go I got it if he's a couple of
diapers three minutes last time let's do
it alright I see a Simon Says up top
okay we got a Simon and it's a it looks
like a blue flashing light okay button
uh blue red red nope
blue flashing light do I hit if the
serial number contains a vowel oh wait a
second this fuel number serial number is
t0 number is seven four to be one six
okay so it doesn't contain a bell no
vowel okay so what's flashing blue is
flashing then you want to do we got no
strikes or one we have one string then
you want to do blue okay blue
got it blue now it could just goes blue
blue so I go blue blue right if you got
blue blue I just keep playing Simon Says
I think blue blue red no no no no okay
blue blue red blue blue
actually yeah blue blue red
okay blue blue red blue blue red yellow
okay blue blue red green okay so still
alive still life it's blue blue red red
yellow red so blue blue red red green
red nice all right cool okay symbol
keypad we got the candelabra at the six
at AE smushed together in train tracks
okay you only do the six six then you
want to do the train track train tracks
then you want to do the AE they hit a
lot bro nice okay now we have it looks
like a I mean it looks like a map or
like a there's a bunch of dots I mean it
looks like battleship kind of right
right right right
okay so there's a there's it's two green
circles and there's a red triangle above
the one green circle and then there are
those with matching circular markings
okay so let's see it's there's there's a
red triangle
it's like third dot down offended if I
must navigate the white light to the red
triangle you can arrow buttons okay okay
do not cross the line shown in the maze
so where are your uh so so the white
light is on the left bottom okay and the
to it and I could go straight up and I
can go to the right basically to get to
the red triangle if I go to up and four
over the white light is on the left
bottom yep yeah give our day
damnit I cannot even I could sit here
for an hour and figure this out
syndicate sorry we love you too Thank
You syndicates are an adult thank you
that's what an if that guys we blew up
so many times but I think we had a good
run there having great a good run in the
beginning for sure
I feel Vaughn everybody Theo von thank
you guys check out his Netflix special
no offense coming February 26 again
Netflix worldwide at Theo von calm you
can see tour dates and all that other
good stuff and crank text yeah Craig
Texas phone man so I can only fun really
funny blade thanks so much dude thank
you this is awesome
please come back Lawson and Beth murasky
Jason Ali thank you guys for money man I
will see you guys next week
[Music]
you